ces images ont été diffusées jeudi par
le comité d'enquête russe au milieu d'un
champ enneigé on y aperçoit la carcasse
d'un avion ainsi que des débris éparts
et des cadavres Moscou l'assure il
s'agit de l'endroit où un avion
militaire russe s'est écrasé dans la
région de belgorot frontalière avec
l'Ukraine une allégation impossible à
vérifier depuis mercredi la Russie
accuse Kiev d'avoir abattu cet appareil
à son bord 74 personnes dont 65
prisonniers de guerre ukrainien
transporté en vue d'un échange aurait
été tué une accusation réitérée jeudi
lors d'une réunion du Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies consacré à
l'accident toutes les informations à
notre disposition prouvent que nous
sommes face à un crime prémédité et
soigneusement préparé les dirigeants
Ukrainiens connaissaient très bien la
voie aérienne pour le transport des
soldats vers la zone
d'échange de son côté keV confirme qu'un
échange de prisonniers était bien prévu
mais que Lee transport n'était pas connu
l'Ukraine dénonce le manque
d'information fiable sur les passagers
de l'avion et reproche à Moscou d'avoir
délibérément mis en danger les
prisonniers si les informations
indiquant que des prisonniers de guerre
ukrainien étent à bord sans confirmé
cela serait une nouvelle violation
flagrante du droit humanitaire
international par la Russie avec le
premier cas d'utilisation dans les aires
de boucliers humain pour couvrir le
transport de
missile l'Ukraine ne confirme pas avoir
abattu l'av et demande l'ouverture d'une
enquête internationale pour éclaircir
les circonstances de l'accident l'armée
affirme qu'elle continuera ses opération
dans la région russe de Belgorod un
oblast régulièrement visé par des
attaques de missile et de drones
Ukrainiens en réponse au multipes
bombardement russes de
l'Ukraine